problème pour nous en martinique va se
poser là nous avons tenu longtemps dans
cette épidémie nous avons tenu nous
avons eu de la chance mais en même temps
nous avons réussi à maîtriser cette
épidémie ben on parle de possibilité de
quelques cas supplémentaires peut-être
bien puisque le confinement n'a pas été
quand même à ce point étanche
mais le gros problème ce sera la
réouverture des frontières nous sommes
une île
donc nous vivons des changes donc cette
réouverture est nécessaire mais pas
n'importe comment
donc elle doit être sécurisé accompagner
le problème des avions est fondamental
quand vous avez trois compagnies
aériennes qui vont déverser un minimum
de 750 personnes par jour en martinique
bon il est difficile à ce moment-là
d'envisager des 14 n d'abord c'est
illégal et 14 aides en un seul lieu
mais en plus même dès 14 heures à
domicile seront plus respectés donc il
faut protéger les avions à l'entrée
parce qu'en plus de ça au bout de huit
heures il y à de fortes possibilités que
les gens puissent attrapé quelque chose
il y a eu des études de fait comme ça
sur d'autres virus sur d'autres
bactéries en fonction du temps de vol en
fonction du recyclage des avions et nous
avons vu tout récemment des problèmes
arrivée dans l'île soeur de la
guadeloupe donc ce que personnellement
je pense avec pas tout seul beaucoup
d'autres confrères et c'est aussi le cas
d'ailleurs du reste de la caraïbe qui va
tester mais je pense qu'il faut tester
avant à l'entrée bon cela nous avons un
outil
il est environ 10 plusieurs types de
tests la majorité d'entre eux sont
utilisables dans le domaine de
diagnostic de la clinique
mais il existe des tests rapides
portable un petit peu comme le genre de
test qu'utilisent les diabétiques sur
une goutte de sang qui peut déjà nous
donner une idée de la présence ou de
l'absence du contact avec le virus
bien sûr c'était sont perfectibles en
fiabilité dit-on taux de 70% maintenant
qui va s'améliorer certainement donc la
réponse ne nie pas ce simplement un seul
outil n'est pas autour du test mais
autour d'une succession de filtres donc
il faudrait à notre avis est rogné en
tout cas faire un test de ce genre à
l'entrée des avions et à la sortie
supplémenté ce test par des prises de
température l'idée c'est que de créer
une espèce de mille feuilles mais d'une
série de filtres qui permettrait de
laisser passer le moins possible donc à
la fin si un ou deux individus par
malheur échapperait d'abord une serait
pas en état infectieux donc une échec
très pâle reste l'avion et deuxièmement
ça ne changerait pas grand chose par
rapport à la situation du virus dans
l'île encore une fois il me semble qu'il
ya d'autres tests en arriver parce que
on est en train de dire qu'il y a une
espèce de balle magique quelque chose un
test qui pourrait sécuriser de a à z non
mais une succession d'une succession
d'éléments mise en place de manière à
filtrer au maximum et permettre aux gens
de voyager avec un espèce de filet
sanitaires car ça c'est l'intérêt des
voyageurs c'est aussi l'intérêt de la
compagnie on a dit d'un point de vue
juridique
mais c'est aussi l'intérêt des navigants
nous avons des compagnies où nous avons
des navigants d'ailleurs certainement
dans certains d'entre eux venant de la
martinique de la guadeloupe qui sont
notre personnel navigant qui vont et qui
viennent en permanence et qui sont en
première ligne dans ces cas là
j'interroge aussi les compagnies
aériennes quid des risques doit du
travail puisque vous savez que
l'employeur doit absolument démontrer
qu'il a protégés de manière efficace tôt
ses employés